alors jacques dutronc est ce que comme
tous les garçons et les filles de votre
âge elle est un peu fatiguée là pourquoi
pas ce qu'on va faire une interview tous
les garçons et les filles
est ce que comme tous les garçons et les
filles de votre âge vous regarder des
chiffres et des lettres
non est ce que comme tous les garçons et
filles de votre âge vous pensez qu'il ya
plus de jeunesse et un plus de printemps
surtout way ainsi comme tous les garçons
les filles votre âge est attiré par le
bouddhisme
non non c'est trop grave et je suis
comme tous les garçons les filtrages ou
porter des thermolactyl de damart
non ça sans me est ce que comme tous les
garçons les filles votre âge
politiquement vous avez viré à droite
j'ai mis mon clignotant à gauche
est ce que comme tous les garçons et
filles de votre âge vous appeler les
flics quand les jeunes font trop de
bruit assure n'ont pas est ce que comme
tous les garçons les filles de votre âge
vous avez peur de mourir
oui enfin ça pourrait être un peu plus
longue la réponse mais ça et je suis
comme tous les garçons et les filles de
votre âge vous surveillez votre taux de
cholestérol même nom n'y a aucun
problème cholestérol
tout est très bon est ce que comme tous
les garçons les filles de votre âge vous
êtes susceptibles quand on vous parle de
votre âge
non parce que ça se voit alors oui pas
tellement est ce que comme tous les
garçons et les filles de votre âge vous
dormez devant votre télé le samedi soir
non
trop la vie aux éditions du seuil